think of the solar system as a cookbook
on the last page is a picture of the
solar system that you're going to make
but what's the recipe for making the
solar system that we still have to learn
if you look at our solar system almost
all of it is the Sun and then the
leftovers from when the Sun formed that
made to better and then the leftovers
from when Jupiter formed made everything
else so that means if I want to know how
do I get to making these other planets I
better figure out Jupiter next but
nobody's ever really gone close enough
to make the type of high fidelity high
accuracy measurements that our science
instruments are going to make we're
going really close to Jupiter into its
big strong magnetic field diving
underneath it's dangerous radiation
belts looking at the planet in a way
that's never been seen before I've
thought about what that moment will be
like when we see the first data coming
down
there be nothing there will it be
exactly the way the models predicted and
I have no idea how I'm going
that I can understand and look into
depth at the jet streams and the storms
on Jupiter that might teach me a little
bit more about how weather patterns form
on the earth you know a hurricane on the
earth that might get is driving energy
from the difference in temperature
between the ocean and the land on
Jupiter a storm could get its energy
from the interior to the exterior that
comparison could teach us something
about how the weather works here on the
earth a single most important number
that we'll get back from Juno will be
the global water content of Jupiter
because that tells us about how the
planets formed have one number how much
water does it have is a really key
number that we need to figure out how
did the solar system get here I think
the thing that's most interesting to me
is how much we can learn about the
inside of the planet when everything we
measure is outside we will measure
Jupiter's magnetic field and that will
tell us a lot about the origin of
Jupiter but it also helps us answer some
fundamental questions about how two
planets make magnetic fields I'm really
interested in understanding what the
interior is going to tell us about how
the solar system form and how it works
and what it's made of those things lead
to the discoveries that make up all the
things human beings have learned how to
do it's just you can't predict which
thing is going to turn out to be the
most important discovery ever and which
thing is going to be a curiosity that's
written in the textbooks and it doesn't
get used for anything else Juno is gonna
be our first really good shot at
learning how did the solar system form
how two planets form where do we come
from